salut la tum menthe à l'eau c'est le
jour des explications je me suis pas
approché un peu trop près de la caméra
c'est pas grave je continue quand même
c'est le jour des explications donc je
vous explique quelque chose pour bluffer
les gens mais un petit peu différemment
parce qu'on va pas parler ni d'un tour
de mentalisme ni d'une expérience menée
à tours de magie mais quelque chose
dusable et applicables au quotidien bien
la suggestion la semaine dernière je
vous ai parlé gentiment d'hypnose
c'était vraiment survolé de chez survolé
aujourd'hui c'est pareil c'est encore un
survol sur la suggestion vous allez
pouvoir faire une action dans le
quotidien qui va complètement bluffé les
gens vous allez agir sur des petits
problèmes physiques très léger et votre
suggestion dans la plupart des cas va
déclencher un effet placebo chez la
personne deux explications pour le prix
d'une donc aujourd'hui première
explication si quelqu'un a mal à la tête
si quelqu'un souffre de douleurs à la
tête faut pas que ce soit trop violent
on parle bien de petits maux de tête
vous allez lui proposer de les faire
passer le vrai secret pour ça c'est que
vous devez être autoritaire pas
autoritaire dans le sens lui crier
dessus se sert à rien d'hurler arrêté
non autoritaire dans le sens faire
preuve de compétence vous savez ce que
vous faites à aucun moment vous devez
dans l'hésitation ou faire semblant
d'hésiter sur quelque chose vous devez
être franc déterminé directif vif vous
expliquer à la personne que vous savez
comment on fait passer les maux de tête
tout ça y'a pas de soucis vous savez
très bien faire on vous l'a appris il ya
quelques années c'est efficace à 100%
vous passez derrière lui et vous appuyer
fermement avec deux doigts sur les
tempes comme ceux ci et avec vos pouces
qui vous restent parce qu'en temps
normal vous êtes équipé d'une paire de
pouce c'est très pratique elle voulait
placer ici c'est à dire à la jonction
entre la mâchoire et le coup essayez de
vous le faire sur vous même vous avez
trouvé il ya un endroit où quand on
appuie fermement ça fait une sensation
un petit peu inhabituel en tout cas ça
puis un petit peu sur le muscle du coup
et en même temps ça repose sur la
mâchoire
c'est pas un point qu'on a l'habitude de
ressentir donc vous passez derrière la
personne vous mettez les douala les
pouces derrière et vous appuyer
fermement pendant une minute pendant
sept minutes l'a voulu parler en lui
demandant d'expirer très fort cinq fois
d'affilée dix fois et de se détendre au
maximum de se décontracter l'année comme
ça durant une minute une minute trente
et avant de relâcher tous a expliqué que
quand vous aurez terminé la personne
n'aura plus mal à la tête ce sont des
points très efficace pour calmer le sens
qu'elle dans les régulations de la tête
inventer inventé mais soyez déterminer
quand vous inventez soyez autoritaires
comme si vous saviez exactement ce que
vous faisiez la personne ne doit pas
avoir de doutes sur l'efficacité de ce
que vous faites
et quand vous aurez terminé vous allez
voir que la personne n'aura plus mal à
la tête
ces simples suggestions associées à un
contact physique déclenché un léger
effet placebo qui fait que la personne
va s'auto guérir sur son mal de tête
on sait à quel point le cerveau peut
influer sur le corps al'inverse ya même
des personnes qui somatise et bien là
c'est la version positive
vous pouvez aussi l'appliquer à
quelqu'un qu'elle est ok si quelqu'un a
le hoquet vous explique comment moi je
fais comme une personne n'allait ok je
lui explique que je sais très bien faire
passer les hoquets que j'ai une
technique infaillible pour ça mais c'est
pas une technique en genre une technique
non là c'est un truc efficace qui marche
qui marche très très bien
je prends sa main et j'appuie sur un
point de shiatsu c'est vrai c'est un
point de shiatsu qui est juste ici en
médecine asiatique mais c'est pour la
constipation donc rien à voir mais là
personne ne sait pas j'appuie ici parce
que ça fait une sensation aussi un petit
peu étrange et je masisi entre le pouce
et l'index et tout en massant je regarde
plus la personne je regarde juste ce
point là je fais des trucs bizarres en
étant concentré en comptant j'ai
j'appuie je fais 1 2 3 4 5 6 8 10 rbds
jamas un petit peu je rappe hui je
compte jusqu'à quatre jeux mass un peu
rapide compte jusqu'à 3 je me sens un
peu et c'est jusqu'à 0 juste avant de
commencer je demande à la personne de
focaliser son retard sur ce point là et
en même temps mentalement d'imaginer que
son ok a disparu j'ai peint tenue de
statistiques mais je pense grosso modo
que neuf fois sur dix ça a fonctionné
après une fois que le hockey a disparu
vous pouvez vous amuser à expliquer le
non c'était pas ça du tout vous allez
utiliser une suggestion pour déclencher
un effet placebo vous pouvez lui
expliquer comment vous avez fait et lui
faire partager aussi ce petit savoir là
pour qu'elle puisse le faire à d'autres
personnes
mais dans l'instant il est important
qu'elles soient convaincus que vous ayez
la connaissance et la compétence de
faire ça j'espère que cette double
explication d'aujourd'hui vous a plu je
les mii dans l'explication du dimanche
parce que quand vous avez le faire à
quelqu'un vous allez voir que ces bleus
font aussi bien pour la personne que
pour vous c'est également une autre
manière d'aborder le mentalisme si ça
vous a plu n'hésitez pas à me le faire
savoir en laissant un petit généreux
gracieux poussant n'hésitez pas à mettre
un commentaire au bas de la vidéo vous
savez que je les lis je sais que vous
savez vous savez que je sais vous
passé un excellent dimanche n'oubliez
pas de vous abonner en cliquant ici ou
en dessous avant de partir et rendez
vous demain à 17 heures parce que le
mental blog c'est une vidéo par jour
pendant un an
ciao